monsieur le
président
[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le contteenduit
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site chacun observera des
valeurs pour nous qui sont importantes
même essentiel le respect des uns et des
autres mais aussi très concrètement le
respect du temps temps de parole et je
donne immédiatement la parole à notre
collègue Franck Menonville pour le
groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier ministres mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Agriculture elle porte sur
la colère des agriculteurs qui se
propage de façon très inquiétante dans
notre pays mais avant de la poser je
voudrais avoir une pensée émue pour
Alexandra Sonac et sa fille qui ont
tragiquement perdu la vie dans
l'Arriège comme vous le savez monsieur
le ministre la colère des agriculteurs
ne tombe pas du ciel elle sanctionne une
longue évolution au fil des années les
attentes écologiques et sociétales
pesant sur le monde agricole n'ont cessé
de croître tandis que leur charg
administrative et financière n'ont
cessaiit d'exploser à cela s'ajoutent
des politiques publiques françaises et
européennes inadaptées aux réalités
quotidiennes de leur métier de moins en
moins capétitive notre agriculture a
subi un véritable déclassement résultat
nous importons aujourd'hui 2,2 fois plus
qu'en 2000 à horizon 2027 nous pourrions
même perdre notre indépendance laitière
monsieur le ministre pour enrayer cette
évolution il faut agir vite et fort pour
se faire vous devez porter des mesures
de de court terme aux effets immédiats
dé fiscalisation du GNR l'octroit d'une
année blanche pour des agriculteurs les
plus fragilisés des allègements de
charge fiscal et social la suppression
des surfaces non productives vous devez
aussi vous attacher à faire veiller à la
stricte application de la loi égalime
quant aux mesures de long terme il faut
un alignement des réglementations
françaises au standard européen et un
choc de de simplification monsieur le
ministre vous disposez d'un véhicule
législatif laala comptez-vous y intégrer
des mesures fortes pour restaurer la
compétitivité de notre agriculture
soutenir cette profession aujourd'hui
désespéré et enquête de sens depuis tant
d'années pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur F
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Ménonville merci de votre
question et je voudrais d'abord en début
de ma réponse m'associer à votre émotion
à l'émotion de toute une profession et
avoir mes pensé dépensé pour cette jeune
femme pour sa très jeune fille pour son
époux pour toute sa famille qui a été
victime hier ces deux jeunes femmes ont
été victimes hier d'un accident terrible
dans la riège et je sais que l'émotion
est très grande dans ce département est
très grande dans la communauté agricole
comme dans l'ensemble de la communauté
nationale et je voulais m'associer à cet
hommage cette jeune femme elle défendait
la fierté de son métier elle défendait
la nécessité d'un revenu elle défendait
aussi ce qui est parfois vécu pour
beaucoup d'agriculteurs comme des
incohérences et donc nous allons
travailler pour apporter des réponses
des réponses de court terme sur un
certain nombre de sujets des réponses de
moyen et long terme premier sujet c'est
les questions de rémunération nous avons
besoin que la loi égalim soit respectée
dans son entièreté le respect des
matières premières agricoles le respect
des clause et la nécessité de
contractualiser et les détournements
qu'on peut voir ici ou là par un certain
nombre d'opérateurs et puis la
responsabilité que doivent prendre les
distributeurs et un certain nombre
d'opérateurs deuxième élément il faut un
certain nombre de mesures qui pourissent
répondre à des crises sur les questions
fiscales à des crises sur lesquels on a
commencé à répondre je pense à la crise
viticole ou la crise de la maladie
hémorragique épisotique et dans la
continuité de ce que nous avons fait
depuis des années sur la crise viticol
sur la période de gel sur la maladie de
la grippe aviaire nous avons répondu en
continuité sur les crises et puis il
faut qu'on arrive à se projeter dans
l'avenir premier élément qu'au niveau
européen on retrouve la cohérence entre
une transition qui est nécessaire et une
nécessaire souveraineté qu'il faut
réaffirmer en européen en européen dans
un contexte où l'Europe cette année en
2023 en tout cas aura importé 40
millions de tonnes de céréales il faut
s'interroger sur est-ce qu'on sert bien
des objectifs de souveraineté au niveau
européen comme on les pose sur d'autres
registres au niveau énergétique au
niveau médicamenteux au niveau des
technologies l'Agriculure doit être dans
le même registre et puis deuxième sujet
c'est d'assurer au niveau national plus
d'un milliard de de fonds
supplémentaires sur la transition pour
accompagner nos agriculteurs ils ont
besoin qu'on les accompagne dans les
transitions y compris face au défis
climatiques merci la parole est à notre
collègue Daniel sal pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité
territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le monde
agricole est en deillé et je m'associe
pleinement à la peine des proches de
l'agricultrice et de sa fille décédée
hier l'agriculture française est en
crise le malaise est palpable depuis des
décennies il se cristallise aujourd'hui
car la coupe est pleine le revenu
agricole chute inexorablement alors que
le prix de l'alimentation augmente
jamais la question du partage de la
valeur n'a été aussi cruciale les marges
de l'agroindustrie ont atteint 48 % en
2023 la problématique numéro 1 est bien
celle de la faiblesse du revenu agricole
qui épuise les agriculteurs votre
gouvernement et le syndicat majoritaire
font de la diversion en réduisant la
contestation à celle des normes
environnementales à la question des
jachers le syndicat majoritaire agite
l'écologie comme un épouvantail pour
mieux masquer les échecs sinistres des
politiques menées depuis des décennies
organisation d'une concurrence déloyale
confiscation de la PAC par une minorité
dérégulation des mar
vous avez fait du budget alimentaire la
variable d'ajustement pour les plus
modestes le résultat malnutrition pour
les uns désespoir pour les autres ce
système craque de tous les côtés quand
allez-vous faire œuvre de justice
sociale quand allez-vous agir pour que
les paysans et paysad soi rétribué à la
hauteur de leur
travail répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous connaissez bien comme
votre collègue mononville ces sujets il
y a des sujets de rémunération j'ai dit
les questions d'galif c'est d'ailleurs
un texte qui a été voté et largement
partagé sur no bon il faut qu'on faire
arrive à faire respecter et c'est
l'objet des réunions qu'on aura avec le
Premier ministre avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances pour faire
respecter et puis il faut qu'on aille un
appel et qu'on pourra partager ensemble
à la responsabilité de l'ensemble des
opérateurs deuxième élément il faut vous
dites on a fait de l'écologie un
épouvantail collectivement monsieur
salmont pardon parce que quand on vient
accumuler des normes et des contraintes
quand comment voulez-vous que ça soit
perçu par les agriculteurs et on a
besoin collectivement de on a besoin
collectivement de
réconcilier on a besoin monsieur
salmon monsieur salmon on a besoin de
réconcilier or on est bien dans une
situation où les agriculteurs le vivent
en permanence comme une punition ou
comme une mise en accusation c'est pas
vous qui accusez mais cette question est
posée comme ça et je sais Monsieur
salmon que vous êtes sans doute l'un de
ceux qui essaie de le faire avec de plus
de pondération et puis on a un sujet on
a un sujet d'images il faut qu'on arrête
dans les médias et à longueur de médias
de dire du mal de l'agriculture et de de
de montrer une agriculture qui n'est pas
la réalité de l'agriculture française
l'agriculture française elle est
vertueuse elle est performante elle est
qualité elle est plutôt sur un modèle
familial et donc oui il y a besoin de
transition vous m'avez toujours entendu
dire qu'il y avait besoin de transition
donc je ne me défausserai pas le
gouvernement ne se défaussera pas les
transitions mais regardezl regardonsles
à l'Ô de ce qu'est la souveraineté et de
la capacité des agriculteurs à le faire
sinon on bloquera tout et on aura avancé
ni sur un sujet ni sur
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
salement monsieur le ministre vous
oubliez un peu que ça fait 7 ans 7
années que vous êtes au pouvoir
qu'avez-vous fait sur les closuses
miroir dont on entend parler en
permanence qu'avez-vous fait pour une
autre répartition de la PAC avec tous
ces oubliés de la PAC qu'avez-vous fait
pour accompagner massivement la
transition agroécologique dont on a
besoin
absolument les agriculteurs sont en
première ligne ils savent parfaitement
que nous devons agir sans tarder pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique pour
nous adapter mais il faut les
accompagner et aujourd'hui c'est cela
qui manque dans votre politique votre
politique elle est insignifiante à ce
niveau-là et on comprend bien les mois
de toute la profession donc je vous dis
vous avez passé déjà 7 ans il vous reste
quelques années
agissez la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent Duplomb pour le groupe les
républicains Monsieur le Premier
Ministre entendez-vous le cri de colère
de nos agriculteurs ce cri je vais le
faire mien car partageant t tous les
jours les mêmes angoisses les mêmes
incompréhensions les mêmes révoltes ce
qui nous ce qu'ils nous disent c'est
qu'ils ne comprennent plus ce que la
France et son gouvernement veut nourrir
sans produire cultiver sans culture
élever sans élevage il n'accepte plus
les messages de condamnation de tous ces
pseudo experts Caron Clément Rousseau
qui leur donnent des leçons sur les
médias il n'accepte plus d'être
verbalisé pour écobuage alors que durant
les émeutes des milliers d'incendies
criminels sont restés impunis il
n'accepent plus ces interdictions qui
leur empêche de faire leur travail comme
les néonictinoïdes alors que l'on
importe des milliers de tonnes
d'aliments qui en contiennent ils
n'accepent plus les contrôles acharné
qu'il traitent lorsqu'ils traitent pour
protéger leur vergers ou leur culture
alors que toujours plus d'accords de
libre échange sont signés sans contrôle
à nos frontière il n'accepte plus qu'
qu'on les il n'accepte plus qu'on les
bassines avec ces 10 ans méga bassines
qui sont le fruit d'une stigmatisation
d'une minorité qui terrorise la majorité
en un mot il n'accepte plus le poid de
cette folie administrative de cette
technocratie abrutissante qui empêche
tout qui interdit tout qui tue les
paysans petit à petit alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je n'ai pas de question
à vous poserant l'accumulation des
problèmes que l'agriculture rencontre
résume à elle seul le mal français les
mots ne suffisent plus à calmer ce mal
il faut des actes faites rentrer et
retonner vos tigres qui sont de la drale
de la DDT de l'ofb de la ddspp de
l'inspection du travail ou de la police
de l'eau afin qu'il arr C cette pression
insupportable fait terre par des
arbitrages favorables à l'agriculture
tous ces soldats ver du ministère de
l'écologie punitive faites cesser en
même en même temps de votre propre
majorité avec un campfin promoteur de la
décroissance et du Green Deal car en
même temps ne se conjugue pas en
agriculture faites confiance au bon sens
plutôt qu'à cetteuche qu'à cette gauche
bobo qui n'a de cess de donner des leç
et de produire des interdits faites
écrire dans la prochaine lo
d'orientation des mesures qui détendent
la situation normative arrêter la
surtransposition et de r les moyens de
production libérer les paysans de toutes
ces contraintes et laisserles travailler
il demande pas de travailler moins mais
au contraire de pouvoir s entve
continuer de travailler
plus la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveréim
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du plomb ce n'a pas la première
fois que nous discutons de sujet
agricole tant vous êtes engagé je le
sais dans votre groupe il y en a
d'autres sur ces sujets dans cet
hémicycle vous le dites avec vos mots ce
ne sont pas les miens mais au fond le
rabol que vous
exprimez il existe et c'est ce qu'il
faut entendre et c'est ça ce qu'il faut
entendre du ralbol qui s'exprime qui est
une sédimentation d'ailleurs vous
l'aviez très bien dit dans votre rapport
avec d'autres sénateurs une
sédimentation de dizaines d'années de
réglementation superposée chacun a pris
sa part et je prends la mienne parce que
je n'ai pas de difficulté à le faire la
deuxième chose sur laquelle je ne suis
pas d'accord permettez-moi de vous le
dire monsieur duplom ne jetez pas la
vindicte populaire ou agricole les
administrations de l'État au niveau
national je vous le dis comme au niveau
territorial faisons attention prenons
nos responsabilités peut-être
disons-nous que le législateur que dans
nos réglementations nous devons donner
aussi des outils parfois j'entends des
contrôleur qui dit je comprends même pas
la réglementation et donc il faut aussi
entendre ça et donc on a besoin de
travailler sur plusieurs sujets je
voudrais saluer le travail qui a été
fait au Sénat d' unee première loi sur
la compétitivité vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur durplomb qu'on a parfois on dit
qu'on écoute pas assez le Sénat le
Président il est souvent vigilant on a
repris un certain nombre de dispositions
je pense aux dispositions sur la
compétitivité ce qu'on a fait dès à
présent sur le plan de fruits et légumes
je pense au disposition c'était dans un
autre texte sur les groupements fonciers
agricoles je pense aux dispositions
qu'on prend sur les les garanties sur le
foncier ou les garanties d'emprunt tout
ça rejoint la dynamique que vous avez
évoqué et que vous avez porté ici au
Sénat et puis il faut qu'on aille plus
loin ça permettra je neavais
imparfaitement fait de répondre à
Monsieur mononville il faut que dans la
loi d'orientation puisse rajouter des
choses sur la souveraineté alimentaire
et sur la question des normes et puis
sur le budget comme le rapporteur M
invite rappelez que cette année vous
l'avez d'ailleurs voté au Sénat nous
avons 1,2 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires de crédit pour
l'agriculture au service de la
transition de la souveraineté en termees
de
de la modernisation des appareils de
production c'est tout ça qui permettra
de répondre et d'abord sur les objets de
court et moyen terme et sur le long
terme les éléments vous venez de
poser
merci la parole est à notre collègue sa
Omar pour le rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse au Premier ministre
nous avons dans cet hémicycle avec mon
collègue sénateur t Mohamed eu
l'occasion d'alerter le gouvernement sur
un climat social fortement dégradé dans
notre île de maotte mais aujourd'hui
solennellement nous voulons tirer la
sonnette d'alarme sur ce qui se passe
dans notre île à mayott nous subissons
depuis plusieurs années des vagues
d'immigration venant des pays voisins
les Comor et Madagascar dans un
territoire de 374 km² avec une
augmentation de près de 5 % de la
population avec une densité bien sûr de
2600 habitants au kilomè Carr et nouveau
flux de migrants venant de l'Afrique des
grands lacs et la Somalie est venu
s'ajouter ces dernières années un camp
s'est installé dans le stade de la
capitale mamouzu où séjournent plus de
700 personnes danst des familles avec
des enfants ce camp où vivent des
Africains dans des conditions indignes
cristallise ce désarroi de la population
maoraaise qui subit crise sur crise
crise de la ressource en Nau crise de
l'insécurité crise des intempéries ces
derniers jours sur les réseaux sociaux
certains évoquent des risques de guerre
civile et d'affrontement entre les
populations et les et les migrants nous
ne faisons pas partie des gens qui
soufflent sur les braises mais il est de
notre
responsabilité de vous alerter sur la
situation grammatique qui peut
dégénérer depuis lundi les services
publics sont fermés des barrages sur les
routes bloquent l'accès au travail des
maorés et perturb les établissements
scolaires Mayot et au bord du du du Cho
si des initiatives fortes ne sont pas
prises très rapidement Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ma question est la
suivante face à la situation explosive
au corp d'un territoire de la République
quelle action concrète le Gouvernement
entend-il mener pour évacuer le camp qui
s'est formé au cœur de mamouzu et
enrayer ses flux migratoires je vous
remercie pour répondre à la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Mayotte
est une terre de défi c'est une jeunesse
qui a envie de prendre son destin en
main c'est une biodiversité
exceptionnelle ce sont aussi des
difficultés immenses pour la sécurité
pour l'accès à l'eau pour nos services
publics pour l'école et vous l'avez dit
à travers votre question pour
l'immigration alors je vous le dis de
manière extrêmement claire extrêmement
déterminée avec mon gouvernement nous
sommes déterminés à continuer à agir
pour Mayotte déterminé à œuvrer avec
vous avec l'ensemble des élus avec les
Maorais pour l'avenir de Mayotte
monsieur le sénateur maotte connaît une
immigration forte source de tension très
grave et nous avons eu régulièrement
l'occasion d'en parler dans cette
hémicycle notre premier objectif je le
dis ça reste de prévenir les arrivées
irrégulières à à Mayotte en en luttant
contre les filières d'immigration
illégale vous le savez une antenne de
l'office de lutte contre le trafic
illicite de migrants a été créé à Mayot
au début de l'année dernière afin de
renforcer la lutte contre les filières
de passeur et en priorité les filières
africaines les résultats commence à être
là en 2023 six filières ont été
démantelées avec de lourdes
condamnations qui ont été prononcées
jusqu'à 7 ans d'emprisonnement le
deuxième objectif c'est de traiter
beaucoup plus rapidement les demandes
d'asile des migrants qui arrivent à
Mayotte parce qu'évidemment le temps
d'avoir la réponse on le sait il y a des
installations qui se font nous avons
renforcé les moyens de l'auvepra qui
dispose désormais d'une antenne à
Mayotte nous avons également accru les
capacités d'hébergement des demandeurs
d'asile enfin le troisème objectif c'est
évidemment d'expulser plus rapidement
ceux qui n'obtiennent pas le statut de
réfugiés qui n'ont plus rien à faire sur
notre sol les déboutés de l'asile font
systématiquement l'objet de décision
d'éloignement ensuite il faut pouvoir
pouir les exécuter dans les meilleurs
délais nous savons que l'enjeu il est là
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés sur ce
sujet nous obtenons là aussi de premiers
résultats encourageant mais il faut
aller plus loin et nous avons vous le
savez aussi des échanges internationaux
sur le sujet pour être plus efficace en
la matière je le dis l'ensemble de ces
mesures seront renforcées dans le cadre
du plan interministériel de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière chicandra qui
est actuellement en cours de refonte
monsieur le sénateur vous avez évoqué
dans votre question un point spécifique
une situation spécifique qui est la
situation du stade de Cavani à mamouzu
où s'est installé un campement informel
de migrants et vous avez décrit la
situation je vous le dis de manière très
claire comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
faire sur les autres points l'État est
déterminé à évacuer ce camp en lien
étroit avec les élus concernés et je
vous le dis les premières démolitions
démarreront dès demain elles se
poursuivront dans les prochains jours
jusqu'à la disparition complète de ce
campement nous apporteront une réponse
adaptée à chacune des personnes
présentes sur le campement j'ai bien
conscience des mouvements qui sont nés
en réaction à l'installation de ce
campement les manifestations les
blocages de routes de service public je
le dis de manière très claire le
démantèlement du camp doit permettre le
retour à un fonctionnement normal de
l'ensemble des activités c'est une
attente forte des Maorais et nous le
leur devons mais je veux aussi le dire
les violences à l'encontre des migrants
ne sont pas acceptables 11 auteurs de
ces violences ont été été interpellés et
seront jugés monsieur le sénateur
Mayotte c'est la République avec mon
gouvernement avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres maire je suis
déterminé à agir pour les Maorais à agir
pour Mayotte et j'aurai l'occasion de me
rendre prochainement sur place je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre meddeviel pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
République Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ma question porte
sur les crises concomitantes de
l'Agriculture et de la Pêche tout
d'abord mes pensées vont bien sûr vers
la famille Sona si durement éprouvé
comme prévu le blocage de de la 64 sur
mon département initié par des éleveurs
victimes de la crise bovvine MHE est en
train de se généraliser à l'ensemble du
pays nos agriculteurs nos éleveurs ne
peuvent plus vivre de leur métier devant
tant de désespéran des mesures concrètes
et immédiates sont aujourd'hui
indispensables le gel du prix du GNR en
niveau acceptable pendant 3 ans
permettrait aux exploitants les plus
durement touchés de se refaire une
trésorerie envisagez-vous cette option
aujourd'hui le bashing agricole et
l'inflation normative ne sont plus
supportables l'agriculture doit devenir
grande cause nationale pour
2024 que dire maintenant de la décision
ahurissante du Conseil d'État revenant
sur l'arrêté dérogatoire du gouvernement
et qui se résume à une interdiction de
la pêche pendant 30 jours dans le golf
de Gascogne
les pêcheurs ont subi cet hiver de
nombreuses tempêtes les obligeant à
rester à quai cette nouvelle punition
les met dans une situation tout à fait
insupportable alors que la gestion des
quôas de pêche et de la ressource
aliotique ont été délégué à Bruxelles le
Conseil d'État estil vraiment compétent
pour prendre ce genre de décision la
réalité des faits c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant de dauphins dans le
golfe de Gascogne dont personne ne
souhaite la mort évidemment doit-on
sacrifier toute une filière pour
satisfaire des associations comme sheer
France Nature Environnement ou la LPO où
vont s'approvisionner les marilleeurs
l'écologie punitive a fait suffisamment
de dégâts dans notre pays tournons vite
la page monsieur le ministre nos
territoires nos ports sont en détresse
absolue ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faut en
urgence penser au cevet de ces filières
sous peine d'abandonner toute ambition
en matière de souveraineté
alimentaire pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique monsieur Christophe Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Pier
mviel vous évoquez la situation des
agriculteurs et la situation des
pêcheurs et c'est la deuxième partie de
votre réponse qui va justifier que je
vous réponde pleinement comp tenu à la
fois des responsabilités que j'ai été
amené à prendre ces derniers jours et du
fait que je suis leur
interlocuteur j'insisterai pas sur
l'agriculture Marc fenau l'a fait vous
citez une attente une mesure nous
attendons dans l'après-midi les
revendications précises des agriculteurs
vous savez que il y a ce sujet sur le
génère il y en a manifestement d'autres
et l'examen que nous devrons faire il
sera minutieux il sera avec attention et
il sera pas seulement sur les mesures il
sera aussi sur le fait d'aller éviter
par les mots une absence de
considération ou une forme d'hypocrisie
écologique qui consisterait à continuer
à appliquer dans notre pays des normes
pour ceux qui se produisent ici et qui
ne s'appliquent pas à ceux qui veulent
faire venir leurs produits dans notre
pays
c'est la même logique et la même
réflexion que nous devons également être
capable de conduire sur la pêche où le
point de départ est très différent le
point départ vous l'avez dit c'est une
décision de justice du Conseil d'État au
mois de décembre à partir d'une réalité
qui n'est pas contestable le nombre de
dauphins échoués sur les plages une
espèce menacée et avec 1482 dauphins
échoués sur la seule période
hivernale après les spécialistes c'est
la survie de l'espèce des dauphins
communs et des marsoins communs qui est
en jeu à partir de ça une position de
compromis consistant à imaginer un
dispositif de conciliation a été mis en
place avec des dérogations le Conseil
d'État a annulé ses dérogations et il a
fait avec un délai trop bref pour que
nous puissions faire autre chose que
d'appliquer strictement cette mesure
pour avoir vu le patron des pêcheurs il
y a quelques jours pour être en dialogue
constant avec eux c'est une batterie de
mesure que nous envisageons d'abord dans
l'urgence pour faire en sorte d'assurer
des indemnisations qui ne mettent
personne sur le carreau ensuite
d'quitter pour éviter que des navires
non français ne viennent pêcher dans nos
eau ENF de contrôle j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir à l'occasion de la prochaine
QAG de cette
séance quelques secondes monsieur
medviel monsieur le ministre merci de V
réponse mais ne laissons pas la
situation sans venimer le temps des
réponse concrète est arrivée je
pense la parole est à notre collègue hen
Cabanel pour le gros Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres Alexandra et Camille sont
décédés hier le monde de paysan dont je
suis les pleurent et la France est en
deuil au nom de mon groupe j'apporte
toute notre compassion à leur famille
elles sont mortes en défendant le métier
et notre agriculture l'une des plus
sûres au monde dans ce contexte de
tristesse et de colère la desence impose
à nous stop à la politique politicienne
ce malêtre on le connaît depuis
longtemps le rapport que j'ai Cigné avec
notre ancienne collègue François ferat
en 2021 pointer les causes
multifactorielles nous ne découvrons pas
le problème du revenu une majorité
d'entre eux sont à 4,80 € de l'heure SDC
quand le SMIC est à 11,65 € nous nous
découvrons pas le problème de la
surtransposition des normes de la
lourdeur administrative du dénigrement
de nos paysans par une minorité je le
répète une minorité car 85 % des
Français les aiment et considèrent
qu'ils jouent un rôle majeur dans leur
alimentation soyons dignes nepposons pas
une agriculture contre une autre cette
diversité c'est notre richesse c'est
notre force notre agriculture doit
s'adapter aux clauses environnementales
mais sans jamais déquilibrer
déséquilibrer pardon l'économie ces
mutationations prennent du temps et il
ne faut pas qu'elles crée une
concurrence déloyale les politiques
publiques que doivent être pensé avec et
par et pour les agriculteurs monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé plus de
contrôle pour l'application de la loi
égalim c'est un minimum de faire
appliquer les lois comment et avec quels
moyens pour la dgsrf entre autres vous
êtes d'accord avec l'objectif de
simplification nous aussi comment
entraîner notre administration dans
cette voie à l'heure où le Conseil a été
remplacé par la défiance et le contrôle
demain je serai iné au Parlement
européen à Bruxelles sur le mal-être des
agriculteurs je réaffirmerai
l'obligation des closes miroir monsieur
le ministre comment convaincre vos
homologues sur cet objectif que nous
défendons
tous pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur FO
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cabanel vous êtes
agriculteur vous l'avez dit nous avons
souvent évoqué ces questions et je
m'associe évidemment à l'hommage que
vous avez rendu aux deux victimes
tragique de de l'Ariège répondre sur
plusieurs sujets c'est vrai que c'est
pas des sujets qui sont tout à fait
nouveaux mais il faut qu'on essaie
d'accélérer sur un certain nombre de
procédures alors je commence sur les
sujets de simplification on a plusieurs
sujets à traiter le premier c'est celui
d'accélérer les procédures vous ne
pouvez pas avoir sur l'eau sur les
bâtiments d'élevage ou sur un certain
nombre d'investissements d'initiatives
que prennent les agriculteurs 3 5 7
parfois 10 ans de procédure où au fond
les procédures sont utilisées non pas
pour s'assurer du bon droit ou
simplement de de de prévenir d'un
certain nombre de risqu mais elles sont
elles sont faites et certains l'assument
comme tel pour empêcher que les projets
puissent naître et on a besoin de
regarder cette question de la durée il
me semble que c'est un élément important
deuxième élément on a besoin d'assurer
de la cohérence on peut pas à la fois
demander à un éleveur d'agrandir son
élevage parce que il y aurait des
questions de bien-être et en même temps
lui donner une procédure qui serait trop
longue et trop lourde et qui lui
empêcherait d'agrandir son élevage on
peut pas à la fois dire à un agriculteur
il faut que vous on maintienne le
pastoralisme et nous avons travaillé sur
sur le sujet vous savez qu'on a eu un
débat la semaine dernière et ne pas
trouver des vois et moyens pour trouver
la la réponse à la question de la
prédation du loup et donc c'est sur tous
ces sujets qu'il faut chercher ce que je
veux montrer là c'est les incohérences
c'est comment il y a des injonctions qui
paraissent extrêmement contradictoires
aux agriculteurs dans la diversité de
leur métier et puis il faut qu'on
répondre aux crises vous êtes dans une
région n avons commencé à répondre aux
crises ça me permettra de répondre sur
la maladie hémorragique on a commencé à
mettre des moyens sur sur la table le
Premier ministre et nous proposerons un
certain nombre de moyens complémentaires
et d'éléments complémentaires pour les
rassurer sur la viticulture et puis
dernier élément on a besoin aussi de
travailler sur les transitions il y a
des territoires en particulier les
vôtres qui sont en grande difficulté du
fait du dérèglement climatique ou du
modèle agricole qui est l' qu est
l'heure on a mis 200 millions d'euros
sur la table dans le dans le cadre du
budget 2024 pour accompagner ces
transitions les investissements les
modèles d'agriculture c'est tout ça
qu'il faut qu'on fasse puis enfin au
niveau européen il faut qu'on travaille
à la fois sur les clauses miroires mais
d'abord je te dis à l'Europe et au
niveau européen qu'il faut qu'on
travaille avec les collègues pour faire
en sorte que nous ne créions pas des
normes qui viennent entraver la la
capacité de production européenne parce
que sinon nous n'y arriverons
pas la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Jean-Claude tissau pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
depuis plusieurs semaines un mouvement
agricole a émergé en Europe et depuis
quelques jours en France où il a
malheureusement était terriblement
endeuillé il n'existe pas un malaise
dans le monde agricole mais des malaises
tant les différences entre les régions
et les filières peuvent être importantes
il y a bien sûr des éléments
conjoncturels comme les alléas
climatiques sanitaire ou la situation en
Ukraine mais il y a aussi Monsieur le
Ministre l'incapacité d'un d'un exécutif
qui après plus de 6 ans au pouvoir
semble davantage sêtre fait le
spécialiste des réponses d'urgence
plutôt que le porteur d'un véritable
projet et nous le constatons encore avec
l'è reppport du projet de loi
d'orientation agricole dont le contenu
actuel est en de ça des attentes des
agriculteurs mais aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues face à cette mobilisation ne
nous trompant pas de diagnostic la crise
est avant tout économique à l'heure où
les géants de l'agroalimentaire se
mènent une guerre des prix toujours plus
fortes dont les agricultteurs sont
toujours les grands perdants et ce n'est
pas en cédant au lobby agroindustriel
sur l'abaissement des normes ni en
revenant sur les avanées
environnementales du pacte vert que nous
répondrons à la situation au contraire
il est plus que temps d'accompagner le
monde agricole dans cette indispensable
transition pour cela rémunérons
l'ensemble des services environnementaux
rendus par les agriculteurs
retravaillons les aides de la PAC
agissons pour une loi foncière qui
permette l'installation et la
transmission et encourageons
l'agroécologie initiée depuis 2014 l'un
des derniers versants est bien sûr de
reprendre la main sur la régularation
des prix les lois égalimes ont été des
échecs seul un travail au niveau
européen le permettra au côté évidemment
de l'encadrement des traités de libre
échange ma question est très simple et
sincère monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous engager cette indispensable
évolution de notre modèle agricole pour
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la la
souveraineté alimentaire merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
tisso je ne vois pas forcément Maisse à
toutes les questions qui me sont posées
compris par vous et donc j'ai essayé de
répondre sur la la diversité vous dites
qu' y a une diversité des
problèmes n'éludez pas la question de la
simplification ou de la question des
normes parce que ça fait partie des
problèmes qui sont posés sur la table si
on ne voit qu'un pan du sujet on fera
une erreur me semble deuxièmement vous
nous dites qu'est-ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement pardon je ne crois pas et
je ne vois pas un agriculteur sur le
terrain dire qu'il faut revenir sur les
lois é Galim il nous demande d'aller
plus loin et de vérifier qu'ell
s'applique et les lois et Galim c'est ce
gouvernement et pas un autre qui l'a
fait monsieur tisso c'est ça la vérité
des choses de vous nous dites il faut
les accompagner dans les transitions
mais qui a mis les moyens sur les
transitions y compris en terme de
produits phytosanitaires si ce n'est
nous pardon vous avez soutenu un
gouvernement qui a interdit des produits
je pense au néonicotinoïdes il y avait
pas un sous pour trouver les
alternatives résultat on s'est trouvé en
situation
d'impasse et donc nous nous avons mis
les moyens 250 million d'euros avec ma
collègue qui travaille sur ces sujets de
la recherche 250 millions pour trouver
des alternatives parce que le le
déclamatif et le déclaratif sur les
transitions si on y met pas les moyens
on n arrivera pas nous le faisons sur
les fonds de souveraineté aussi et puis
troisème élément il faut qu'on travaille
au niveau européen mais essayons de ne
pas opposer les on a besoin de tous les
modèles nous sommes une puissance
exportatrice et nous avons aussi besoin
de modèles qui soi plutôt des modèles
qui viennent satisfaire nos besoins
domestiques comme on dit et donc on a
besoin de travailler sur tous ce sujets
le sujet européen le sujet de la
transition le Saget de Galim faut qu'on
aille plus loin monsieur tissou je suis
sûr qu'on peut le partager mais ne
disons pas qu'on a rien fait en tout cas
ce gouvernement singulièrement sur ces
sujets-là il a beaucoup avancé tant sur
la rémunération que sur les transitions
je vous propose qu'on essaie d'avancer
d'avancer plus loin et plus vite
Monsieur
tisso Merci monsieur le Président ben
écoutez monsieur le ministre je vais
vous prendre au mot allons plus loin et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui à travers
la parole de mon président de groupe on
nous avons demandé auprès du du
président du Sénat